book tv continues now on c-span 2
television for serious readers
next on book tv's afterwards michael
malus reports on the far right movement
and its origins he's interviewed by the
federalists ben dominic
afterwards is a weekly interview program
with relevant guest hosts interviewing
top non-fiction authors about their
latest work
michael malus you are the author of the
new right what is the new right
let me see if i get the definition
exactly correct it's on page four of the
book i believe it is the new right is a
loosely connected group of individuals
united by their opposition to
progressivism which they perceive to be
a thinly veiled fundamentalist religion
dedicated to egalitarian principles and
intent on world domination via globalist
hegemony
the new right is not a term that you
hear thrown around all that much in the
media today what you typically hear more
about is the alt-right at least in
recent years what's the distinction
between the two uh the alt-right is a
subset of the new right the alt-right
would be the members of the new right
who view race
uh as the most important or one of the
most important issues in discussing uh
social political thought
normally the
aspect of framing for conservatism and
the right generally in america
is
backwards looking nostalgia a return to
the past the 1950s or those type of
values how is the new right different
from that that's a great question first
of all i always want to point out to
conservatives that whenever aoc and all
those types alexandria okay
correct the congresswoman from um new
york when they talk about how under
eisenhower the tax rates marginal tax
rates are over 90
make sure to remind them that you are
the ones who want to bring us back to
the 1950s
conservatives have a
misguided nostalgia because nostalgia in
general is a deceptive emotion when we
look back at our own past right we think
about oh
it was so fun then but there were also a
lot of bad times there were stomachaches
there were headaches you know insomnia
we don't remember that so nostalgia is a
tricky emotion and conservatives do the
same thing with american history because
there's this idea that at a certain
point let's say the 50s or 40s things
were great and then the left you know
turned crazy and changed and what i
demonstrate in the book is that
progressivism has been a very straight
line from the contemporary times back to
carrie nation woodrow wilson uh the
founding of the university system and
how it became designed intentionally to
have this elite that's going to run
america so it has been a straight line
through and it is a myth of conservatism
that at some point things were good and
that became corrupted and that's one of
the essential elements of conservatives
and this idea that we've fallen away
from an earlier purer state one of the
things that i want to talk about before
we get into the details of your book is
the trend lines that we've seen
in recent years in terms of the
intellectual argument on the right the
uh
the national nationalist movement the
sort of uh the con strain of
conservatism that rejects libertarianism
believes that it's become too
libertarian on the right is that
something that's part of the new right
as well absolutely so this that
definitely traces its roots back to at
the very least pat buchanan's 1992
campaign and to some extent ross's ross
perot's 1992 campaign as well and has
roots far earlier going back to you know
charles lindbergh america first and and
what was called the old right so this is
not only resurgent within american right
of center thought it's certainly very
prevalent in europe and in many
countries around the world uh and and
basically the left does not know what to
do about this other than paint them all
as effectively nazis i was interested to
read a recent comment from levin
obviously one of the most prominent
conservative intellectual voices now at
the american enterprise institute the
founder of national affairs
who was participating in this national
conservatism conference something that i
think raised the eyebrows of a number of
different folks but he himself said that
he thought conservatism had become in
recent years far too economistic
far too libertarian and that it needed
to reorient itself toward social and
cultural issues as being the prime aim
that they are trying to solve via a lot
of different things but including
government is that consistent with the
new right um no i would say it's not
really consistent then you're right the
new right again is united by their
opposition to progressivism so there
would be certainly some social
conservative elements specifically the
trad cons the traditional conservatives
but there'll be far more uh right wing
than what he is espousing and anytime
you're dealing with a mindset that is
about engagement with the left and
working within the system well that is
what the new right is against
progressivism
defining in terms of our terms do you
view it as something beginning and
arising out of the turn of the last
century woodrow wilson and the like or
has it taken on a different character
more recently than that oh it certainly
has changed over time what i trace in
the book is that in many ways it is a
degeneration of the social gospel the
social gospel is a movement in the 19th
century early 20th century and the
principle of the social gospel was
instead of a salvation being a function
of the individual soul salvation is a
function of a nation and this is why you
have things like no platforming
and having people driven off the
internet basically the idea is these
people have to be banished from the face
of either the nation of the earth
because they cannot be you know thou
shalt not suffer which to live so it's a
very direct line from that in fact the
the book uh in his steps
uh which is where the premise what would
jesus do comes from right which is one
of the seminal uh social gospel books
very popular if you read that book which
i recently did the premise is there's a
city a town rather and everyone goes
through this movement where they ask
themselves what would jesus do right and
very conveniently jesus happens to agree
with whatever they happen to be thinking
and one man is a newspaperman and in his
newspaper he decides to stop having ads
or articles about boxing because that's
barbaric and jesus wouldn't discuss it
and it's a straight line from that to
contemporary you shouldn't be giving a
platform to certain individuals certain
ideologies because that's giving them
legitimacy it's a very very direct line
although they don't even realize what
the origins of this kind of mindset are
a passage from your book the left's
exploitation of the overton window is a
major explanation for how progressivism
increased its control over society
despite ostensible conservative
opposition explain that for me sure the
overton window is the concept that what
can be discussed freely in polite
society
any given point in time so in the 1800s
you could with polite society discuss
you know the benefits of slavery
nowadays you'd be run out of town on a
rail and correctly so uh how the overton
window window works is this let's
suppose you have a number from one to
ten uh and the left would be ten
conservatives would be one the left
screams ten conservatives using the
national review slogan stand a thought
history yelling stop they compromise at
five well the next election you have
five to fifteen fifteen which would have
been unconscionable a few years ago and
this ratchets further and further to the
left
so anytime and i always say conservatism
is progressivism driving the speed limit
um all or virtually all of the great
progressive accomplishments are now
touted and boasted as essential to
conservative thought 20 years later and
in fact richard eli who was woodrow
wilson's mentor uh one of the major
founding fathers of progressivism and a
truly a despicable human being who said
well we shouldn't encourage the masses
to rise up and make them happy in where
they are the last chapter of his
autobiography is called i believe in
equality of opportunity so the con
conservatism at its best is about
studying history and learning the
lessons of history sadly many
contemporary conservatives haven't
actually done their homework so the uh
the modern progressive movement
obviously as you say has has changed
from from this original wilsonian view
how much has that changed the character
of the american culture war experience
we talked in the past about cultural war
issues like the issue of abortion
stretching back to roe v wade in the 70s
you know a number of other issues that
have that have trended upwards and
downwards over time you know think about
the arguments over what we see on tv
that happened in the 1990s over rap
music over all these other things how
much has that shift to the culture war
helped activate the new right i think
what has happened was not a shift so
much as an awareness that there is a
culture war going on in 1992 very
famously at the republican national
convention pat buchanan got up on stage
and said we are engaged in a culture war
and everyone lost their minds including
many republicans gas
mario cuomo who was governor of new york
at the time said culture what does that
mean that's a word they used in nazi
germany because obviously nazi germany
is the only place where culture was
discussed let's let's let's be real you
know having the same intellect as his
son um and
what happened is you would have three
and then maybe four networks and you
would think that there is a despair
disparate opinion across them but
they're all hardcore leftist preaching
hardcore leftist idea with a straight
face and a suit thanks to social media
thanks to the internet increasingly
there was an awareness wait a minute
this is not uh a diff ability to choose
between it's just different poisons so
the new right very much is about ripping
the mask off and again we're talking
about we all learned in school about
yellow journalism you know william
randolph hearst you know the
spanish-american war at what point did
it stop being yellow journalism and
start being decent objective journalism
and that is something that's never
discussed in school and that's something
new right focuses on there's been a sort
of
an anti-elite undercurrent
in the right that
is focused on in a number of different
books
and not just once from the right
perspective you know obviously chris
hayes and twilight of the elites and a
bunch of these other things um
how much of this uh of the new right is
a rejection
of the elite generally the elites of
both sort of ideological coalitions and
their leadership over the past several
decades oh yeah a great deal of it is
about a repudiation of self-described
elites and self-selected elites one of
the points but there's also something
called the circulation of the elites
james burnham who was one of the early
national review people and probably the
earliest point where the national review
conservatives and the new wright would
have agreement had a great book called
the machiavellians and he talked about
four kind of old old-school thinkers and
one of the concepts within there was the
circulation deletes meaning when you
overthrow an elite you're not going to
have egalitarianism you're just going to
have a new elite and to put that into
realistic terms what that means is
hillary clinton will always have more in
common with george w bush than she will
with let's say a janitor who had always
voted democrat unlike her all his life
so having this awareness that there is
going to be someone in power and
awareness of hierarchy is a a
very right-wing thought
but b something that the new right is of
two minds there's some who are against
this and some who are like all right
there's gonna be a hierarchy might as
well be us
i'm more interested in the cultural side
of this but we shouldn't uh ignore the
policy argument sure
there's obviously policy differences
within uh the right that are adjudicated
in all sorts of different ways where
does the new right come down in terms of
their policy priorities as it relates to
the federal government they are
completely all over the map so there is
absolutely no agreement across this
subculture other than who the enemy is
and what the nature of the enemy is
there's those who favor an authoritarian
police state there are those who are
complete anarchists and you have every
there are those who are
internationalists in the sense of you
know i'm going to be a citizen in the
world not in the leftist sense but in
the sense of i don't own allegiance to a
particular nation and there are those
who are america first very proud
americans we're going to take our
country back so across this you're going
to have very little agreement other than
who you are against and that's what's
interesting because the press would like
to everyone to be painted with the same
you know neo-nazi fascist brush whereas
when you set down the people in this
group and say well what do you actually
want you have some types were actually
in favor of returning monarchy not just
any monarchy but a descendant of the
stewards so
it's it's really hilarious when you deal
with any subculture uh how many
different factions there are and people
on the right think that the left is a
monolith well you have the hillary types
and the bernie sanders types and the
jill steins they genuinely loathe each
other
the uh
the pat buchanan element yes you already
mentioned his 1992 speech that speech
was decried by a lot of different people
not just people on the left you
mentioned cuomo
and it was often held up as a standard
or as an explanation for why george h.w
bush lost his re-election uh that type
of thing i don't think actually when you
get into the data there's a strong
argument for that but the point is
buchanan became someone who was a fairly
vilified pig figure on the on the right
after having been fairly popular in the
past it was a nixon man originally of
course
but by the time that
you know uh he was uh rolling around in
the reform party he was being dismissed
out of the movement not just by
nationals
but in fact by the current president
donald trump and rush limbaugh and rush
limbaugh and others as well chart me
this arc of how buchanan goes from being
sort of someone who's vilified and
rejected including by people on the
right to someone who's now viewed in
your own sort of terminology as being a
prophet of what was to come yeah
buchanan is a very interesting figure
and i trace his trajectory and contra
distinction to maria rothbard who he
teamed up with in the 1992 campaign mary
rothbard who's far less known was an
anarchist and a libertarian so rod uh
buchanan basically was richard nixon's
first hire when nixon former vice
president former failed presidential
candidate was considering a run for
president in 68 uh and he
wrote nixon's toast to mao he was there
when nixon was fomenting the drug war
and so on and so forth and he was
regarded as this kind of old school hard
right type of figure
but he became a bit anathema as national
review became more let's say
cosmopolitan in their perspective
william f buckley denounced him as an
anti-semite for some pieces that
buchanan had written and wrote a book
about him called in search of
anti-semitism so you know but many of
these arguments against buchanan are
used uh in contemporary terms against
president trump by many of the same
people or at least their intellectual um
descendants so it's the parallels
between 92 and 2019 2020 are very close
and again it's the same split between
the populist blue collar right and you
know the more urban
coffee club
derogatory term right and this has
happened
just one thing i want to point out about
the 92 election
uh conservatives are supposedly big on
looking at the data well the data shows
that every time from 1970
excuse me 68 through 2016
every time they have run a right winger
they have won every time they have run a
centrist they have lost and that
includes george h.w bush who ran in 1998
as reagan jr
and then he goes to the center raises
taxes and is defeated in 1992. so the
the new rights priorities as a as it
relates to a reformation of the of the
right coalition what does that look like
because there is this debate going on
about which people you know the the
republican party ought to reach out to
or the the ideological right should
orient itself towards uh and you know
for uh in the wake of the 2012 election
for instance there was a whole autopsy
that was looking at the different people
they ought to reach out to how they
ought to reach out to them and obviously
what ended up winning for them in 2016
was a fundamental rejection of that
autopsy and the kind of coalition that
it necessarily presented as a
hypothetical does the new right have a
clear idea of how they'd like to remake
the the coalition of the right yes and
it is in terms of not worrying about
washington and realizing where the
poisoning starts so andrew breitbart the
late andrew breitbart had that quote
that politics is downstream from culture
so very often republicans and
conservatives broadly will look at
washington it'll be wonks and the new
right would argue by the time you're
dealing with politicians in washington
the battle's over because you have
people going through public education
you have them going to the universities
and then getting their information from
the corporate press so by the time it's
a little discussion you're in the fourth
quarter you're down 50 points so
building the coalition is about fighting
hollywood it's about fighting the media
it's about especially denigrating the
universities which is the last step of
the progressive stool and basically it's
not at all an embrace of republican
politics or regarding republican
victories as any sort of guarantee of
fixing this country one of the people
who's newly arrived in washington is the
youngest
member of the u.s senate josh hawley
senator from missouri
he's the first
millennial
senator in terms of
his age he's also one who's breaking
with the orthodoxy of the right on a
number of different fronts most
prominently on technology silicon valley
but one of his more recent proposals has
to do with universities he would
basically demand a number of different
steps from them in order to sort of make
people whole if they were if they were
defaulting on their student right
he has a number of other proposals along
those lines
he also seems to express a willingness
to look at taxing their endowments and
and a number of other steps
do you think those do you think of those
steps as being
implicitly part of the new right oh yeah
anytime you have any attack on the
universities this is very much
right-wing thing and you're right
thinking my personal argument has been
to seize all university endowments and
distribute that money as reparations
because those endowments are the
crystallization of privilege so it's
thinking in terms of things that like
mitt romney would find unconscionable
anathema and it's a lot of okay let's
take these radical ideas and even if
we're not going to advocate for them a
they'll move the overton window because
now we're discussing radicalism and
pushing things in a certain direction
and b it's encouraging people to think
critically and outside the box uh one of
the other essential elements of new
right thought is what people call red
pilling after that documentary the
matrix meaning once you take that red
pill you are understanding that what is
presented to you as fact in the media
and entertainment and in politics is in
fact a carefully constructed narrative
designed to manipulate and control you
and limit preemptively your options of
thought so the new right has been
depicted i would say
uh in
the mainstream media or i should say i
think the old corporate the corporate
well the reason let me just interrupt
you please the reason it's always
corporate press and not mainstream media
is because these people are not
mainstream this is a radical ideology
intent on complete control of american
culture so
their depiction is typically just as
these are a bunch of racists
why is that wrong uh well it's not wrong
because people use language differently
and for them racism means that which is
not progressive i have a list in this
book of things that have been described
as racist in the in the press including
peanut butter and jelly milk talking to
minorities not talking minorities moving
into minority neighborhoods moving out
of minority neighborhoods noticing other
races not noticing other races and in
fact there's a great um
tweet that someone said just put into
google is blank racist whatever word you
want and see if there's going to be some
think piece about it and inevitably
things like swimming pools parks
bubblegum are all regarded as racist so
one of the focuses on the new right is
if you left let the left define terms
and racism is one of their big tactics
and you say well no i'm not a racist
right away you're seeking their approval
and these are people who are not
engaging in good faith uh and in fact
one of the other things i point out in
the book is they always you know now
it's gone from racist to neo-nazi white
supremacist fascists far more white
supremacists and white nationalists died
fighting the nazis then did urban
feminists so even historically to
conflate these two groups is inaccurate
you uh you view this through a couple of
different lenses and you have a number
of figures throughout the book you've
mentioned a couple of them in buchanan
and rothbard who are some of the other
critical historical figures in this
progression and the growth of the new
right oh i would certainly say einrand
uh the famous novelist she was a
precursor to this idea but i think the
two
it's it's not a um figurehead driven
movement there are many people i discuss
in the book ann coulter uh the racist
jared taylor um uh mike cernovich milo
uh people like uh jim goat i called the
godfather the new right he was a
heretical thinker and still around to
this day but it is very much um more of
an al qaeda uh cell structure than
having this kind of these are the ten
leaders and if you take them out then
this movement is going to go away the
corporate press would like to paint it
as this is the trump phenomenon or well
we got rid of milo so therefore this
movement's done and it's not about
either these men it's much more populist
in its uh formation than uh it has and
this is a function of social media this
would not have been possible 20 years
ago is the president a part of the new
right
uh uh well he's on the cover of the book
so i i don't i don't know if he would
identify as a member of the new right i
i don't know how he views progressivism
or if he views is he's that intellectual
let me ask this a different way is he
instinctually aligned with them oh
certainly uh the content the way he
treats his opponents with complete
contempt and dismissal is a
intentional new right tactic whether he
uses intentionally or not when he trolls
people and forces them to drop their
veneer of respectability and act like
loons that is a new right tactic
how
dangerous is the new right as it relates
to the existing
uh corporate and and media and think
tank reality uh in terms of how
washington has worked for uh not
dangerous enough yet so hopefully
they'll turn the dial up to level part
of that organic kind of nature of their
system that they don't have so many
alternate institutions to use instead
well and the the problem is since you're
united by opposition it's very hard to
build an institution because all you're
agreeing about is okay those people are
bad but what do you want well you're not
going to get anywhere we're seeing this
actually in england so brexit passes you
know there's a small margin but a
significant margin okay we're going to
get out of the eu well what is that
getting out of the eu going to look like
and there's they had seven votes and
they couldn't get a majority on any of
these options so yeah you can get 51 to
a great percent 50 to agree to a broad
idea but once you start okay what's this
going to look like you have seven
choices and each of those are going to
get 30 so it is not uh it's not very
much a governing coalition in that sense
you uh mentioned the uk and i wanted to
get to that uh eventually uh to what
extent is the new right a particularly
american phenomenon given that we see
all of these think pieces and the like
suggesting that what we're seeing is a
global rise of sort of nationalism
populism and the like in the wake of
financial crises and a lot of other
things that have people very upset uh i
i think it's it would be very convenient
for people to see you know um glenn
greenwald had this great visceral attack
on the new york times when they're
referring to bolsonaro who's the new
president of brazil as the
trump of the tropics and he goes he's
talking about executing people he's
making jokes about i mean just the most
defensive things and talking about
military coups trump is not even close
to that so to view everything as a
function of the united states is very
much a premise that people who read the
new yorker subscribe to but is a very
inaccurate one because many of these
other countries where you're seeing a
resurgence of right-wing nationalism
they actually do have fascist and
neo-nazi roots it's not just a smear
from the corporate press it's a direct
line in these parties from nowadays to
the 40s and 30s
you uh you talk a bit about uh the
symbolism of shea for a number of young
leftists yes um
tell me a little bit about the effect
that
as sort of an embrace of that type of
ideology on the left has driven more
people into the arms of the new right
well i think it's more function of che
guevara was a huge racist huge homophobe
mass murderer he talked openly about
wanting to nuke new york he said that
he's a machine driven by hate these are
all you know quotes of his and hillary
clinton named her either cat or dog che
uh people wear the chase shirt all the
time that iconic chase shirt there's
also a reagan version which kind of
looks pretty cool um and i will defend
that because very often can i just
interject the mayor of new york also
recently got in trouble for quoting shea
in florida and not having the reaction
that he thought yeah yeah exactly um but
i do think it's true that a figure
historical figure can be divorced from
their reality and become kind of this
mythic uh you know call to arms uh the
new right has their own corresponding
figure who's far less known who was
pinochet who was the dictator of chile
from 1979 through the 90s and he
basically there was a communist
government and whenever communist
governments uh take place very quickly
mass murder happens the consequence he
led a military coup against allende and
what he's uh known for this is very dark
humor but sometimes it's not humor than
you right he took many of these
communists up in hell and innocent
people up in helicopters and threw them
into the ocean so very often you'll have
some corporate journalists on on twitter
prattling about how you know trump's
july 4th military parade was exactly
like 10 minutes tiananmen square and
instead of engaging with them no you're
wrong the response will simply be the
helicopter emoji the
uh the sort of shay
castro
uh fetishization of some of these uh
some of these violent socialists um how
real is it and how much is it sort of
the equivalent of what a lot of new
right trolls sort of do
in response to the left how real is what
how real is that embrace on the left i
don't think it's that it well it depends
you're going to have the ones who are
knowingly the tankies that they're
called on twitter who are knowingly and
consciously embracing this and then
there are people who are just hankies
i mean people are like sending the tanks
who are like all of all favor and favor
that i mean these are the the stalinists
the actual stalinists um and then there
are those who just have no idea in fact
and i made this point when castro died
and he died on pinochet's birthday
ironically enough and there was a meme
where god is talking to pinochet and
says augusta what do you want for your
birthday you know
i think it's wonderful that we live i
was born in the soviet union that we
live in a nation where people can be so
privileged that they have no idea what
living in cuba means that they have no
idea what living in the soviet union
means and it is the fault of the right
wing where we are told constantly and
correctly about slavery about jim crow
and the holocaust that there's not any
discussion or very little about what
life is like under communism this needs
to be a mantra from the right wing
reagan and thatcher end in the cold war
without firing a shot but we don't hear
about it and this you can't expect the
left to talk about it because the new
york times still as of this morning is
singing the praises of the soviet union
although they covered up stalin's
genocide of ukraine in the 30s uh why is
the right wing not constantly talking
about what communism means in practice
it's unfathomable to me
one of the things that's in common
between buchanan perot
and president trump is a rejection of
what is typically viewed as the widely
held positions of those in the
pro-capitalist right yes in favor of
free trade yes
what do you view as the kind of trade
aspect of this and is there something
about that particularly that makes it a
new right issue or is it something
that's happening for different reasons
well i think across the new right you're
going no matter where you have the
anarchists you have the nationalists or
anyone between there is going to be a
very strong skepticism of international
globalist corporations
so historically you know the country
club republicans would be defending
corporations and and to some extent
understandably so and now you see how
blindly these corporations are putting
forth progressive bromides without
batting an eye it's just like
regardless of what you think about gay
rights like the day uh you know pride
month happens all their logos turn
rainbow the day pride month ends all
their logos go back to normal and
there's a shameless sociopathy to it
because whenever
there was a kind of something to lose by
advocating for gay rights they were
nowhere to be found and now they will
say with the straight face that we're
leading the fight when if you go to
times square it's rainbows all around it
looks like a lisa frank poster so the
idea that um
uh you know there's a big skepticism of
internationalism and globalism and again
that's going to tie in the skepticism of
international corporations and their
agenda we live in an era of of
comprehensive digital corporate wokeness
oh yes uh the the kinds of things that
you're talking about you know where uh
where
organizations corporations have nothing
to do with the agenda involved kind of
try to sidle over and virtue signal for
all sorts of different things um and you
know for instance i i honestly wish the
nfl for instance would spend a little
bit more time talking about brain health
than they do wearing ribbons
but
to your point
it seems to me that that's something
that's only going to drive people into
the arms of the new right because that's
a clear split between the kind of
chamber of commerce big business
attitude in which that virtue signaling
is just something they do to increase
their profit and the feelings of many
americans that those embraces or those
advocacy sort of things are a
declaration of of uh picking a side in
the cultural world yeah i mean you have
to be think how insular you're thinking
in your worldview has to be
if you would tell your cashiers who are
low status low paid people to talk to
your customers about race which is the
touchiest subject perhaps in american
culture and this is exactly what
starbucks did uh it's instead of
something that everyone could agree on
about let's say let's talk to them about
being kind to each other or hey yeah i
did something nice today which you would
think of universal it's it's instead the
most tendacious subject but from their
perspective it's it's something that we
all agree on at the same time if you
look at from another perspective
uh people who are pro-choice uh which i
would include myself would certainly say
hey adoption is a great thing uh you
know we don't want these unwanted kids
suffering this is a but if you had a
starbucks corporation saying we should
have our cashiers encouraging people to
talk about adopting kids the bloodbath
would be immense and that just speaks to
why this is a totalitarian faith as
opposed to a difference of opinion
there's a
there's an aspect of that corporate
wokeness
that i think
we need to talk about in this context
which is that
as we've seen the rise of of
increasingly aggressive progressivism on
campuses yes that has started to flow
out of the academy yes where it's
influencing the lives of obviously
students and professors and into the
corporate sphere the uh the huma uh the
human resources sphere absolutely into
the hiring decisions that that are being
made there are a lot of people in
america who are on the right who are
concerned about that but i also feel
like there are a lot of apolitical
people who are concerned about it just
that they will say the wrong thing in
that context tell me how much that's
part of this sort of new right
phenomenon and that and that push back
that you've seen to it absolutely so one
of the big
ways that the progressives start to lose
or something called gamergate where
basically the idea became that even in
video games you have to have this kind
of progressive ideology and there's a
1960s expression that says the personal
is the political so many people who are
you know right of center or even left of
center or apolitical think well i could
just live my life and not have to deal
about politics in the same way that i
personally don't think about sports and
they what they realize and increasingly
realize is there's nowhere for you to
escape even sci-fi movies fantasy movies
video games uh escapism designed to lead
the literal earth
still you cannot escape this
totalitarian fundamentalist faith and
that to many people once you see the
mass drop and realize they will search
you out and make sure that you agree
with them that is what's driving many
people to this uh perspective as opposed
to the conservative respect where it's
like well no we're not that bad uh that
that just means you're gonna be the ones
who are shot last corporate media uh
tends to like to run with a certain type
of story which i'm sure you've seen many
examples of many such cases where they
will where they will uh there'll be some
new announcement a casting decision for
instance yes disney uh recently you know
uh cast a young african-american i
believe actress as as the next little
mermaid in their live action uh since
they have to make the same ideas and
stories over and over and over again
sure and there were a couple of stories
out there
including a couple from major media
sites about a supposed backlash against
this casting right and yet the examples
that they would use were typically
tiny twitter accounts or social media
postings from individuals
not some kind of organized pushback or
petition campaign or anything like
how much is are things like that
contributing to the feelings that people
have about basically that their opinion
is is always going to be inflamed or
built up to be a much bigger thing than
it is yeah the great contrarian h.l
mencken once said that the average man
does not want to be free he simply wants
to be safe so one of the ways
progressivism dominates is by creating
this impression that all right thinking
are progressive people are progressives
right so they will have these articles
and say look if you disagree with what
everyone's thinking you're a freak
you're an outsider the average person
doesn't want to be picked out because
like a school of fish if you're picked
out you're a target you want to fit in
so very quickly this is a very subtle
technique of getting people to fall in
line
and the insanity of this kind of
approach is will smith was recently
attacked for being cast as serena
williams dad because he wasn't
dark-skinned enough this is an extremely
racist uh mentality that has its roots
at least to the 1930s and earlier uh
something called colorism there was a
book called the black of the berry by
wallace thurman where he discussed there
was these uh very bourgeois social clubs
for african-americans where they
literally had a paper bag test and if
you were darker than a paper bag you
were not being allowed to
be a member and again this talk this
goes to my thesis about progressivism
has been a very hierarchical elitist
straight line from contemporary times
through in this case the 30s and earlier
uh you we have not yet talked about
foreign policy sure
does the new right generally have a uh
consistent thrust when it comes to some
of the foreign policy yes we've had in
recent years bring the troops home and
shut down the bases it is extremely uh
anti-interventionist it is very anti-war
um it is that is another very big
unifying uh thesis and since their arch
enemies woodrow wilson uh you know the
first president who went to europe as as
president and this idea that america has
to be involved in every every every kind
of nation state every continent this is
the exact opposite that we have to worry
about america first but also probably
second third fourth and fifth and sixth
um so that is very much a new right uh
perspective and thankfully what the new
right has done is brought this
respectability to the uh anti-war
perspective on the right wing which has
historically and sadly been discarded by
the hard left one of the challenges with
doing foreign policy from a perspective
that is naturally
uh
let's not say anti-war but war averse
which i think is a good description of
president trump he obviously said was
opposed to the stupid wars and that kind
of thing he seems more willing to
consider
troop deployments closer to home
something like venezuela um
part of the difficulty of that is that
the people who have come up
through the foreign policy establishment
and become part of it
are almost always people who are more
globally minded oh yes uh and that i
would include you know
obviously john bolton in that and a
number of other people who are currently
working for or advising the president
how can the new right change the foreign
policy makeup of the sort of people who
are in the positions of power to make
these types of determinations yeah i i
often say that the uh
the establishments and by establishment
include the corporate press the
establishment's bloodlust for war cannot
be overstated when president trump
bombed syria that was oh he's
presidential for the first time he's
presidential they equate war with being
presidential this is why reagan and
thatcher don't get the respect they
deserve because when they won the cold
war there weren't any bodies and this is
a problem we want corpses everywhere and
it's very very you know we talk about i
said earlier about the yellow journalism
spanish american war it's been a drum
beat for a century uh war war war we
want as much war as possible uh as for
controlling trump and you know
washington and having his appointees
they have very little impact but in
terms of uh having the extreme criticism
of the war machine in you know discourse
this is something the new right is doing
very well this is why of the democratic
candidates they love tulsa gabbard so
much because she is the most anti-war
candidate on the left um and it's just a
function of and this is something that
president trump is very good about i
wrote a piece for the observer a few
years ago meaning if you have a
president who is revered and esteemed
and you know treated highly on a
pedestal like obama people are going to
be a lot less skeptical of when he's
sending our troops overseas which means
people are dying including you know
foreign citizens which you know may be
secondary to american concerns but
certainly is a concern whereas if you
have a president who is regarded as
allowed it's going to be a lot harder
for him to pull off having this kind of
war and that is in the eyes and you
write a very good thing does the success
or failure of the new right depend on
donald trump
not in the slightest and it didn't even
depend on his election uh this is where
the corporate press and the progressives
get it wrong they think it's about trump
trump is great there's an enormous
amount of skepticism and always has been
um from the new right towards trump he's
not an ideologue they regard him as a
wrecking ball they regard him as a
source of great humor they regard him as
a great person in terms of dropping the
mask from the left and it's nature but
in term but in terms of accomplishments
where's the wall uh where are the tanks
in harvard yard as mentioned small bug
advocated uh none of this stuff is
getting any closer to fruition so uh
he's good in terms of what he takes down
but in terms of you know putting forth
their policies i they would say he's a
big disappointment you have uh the rare
distinction in this book of probably
being the first person to quote both
murray rothbard and louis c.k
tell me a little bit about the uh tell
me a little bit about what you see in
the world of comedy one that i know you
pay a lot of attention to
um where
we've seen a number of people there
express views that almost sound like
they're the you know the canaries and
the mine shaft for
the culture warp you know comedians who
are certainly not of the right in any
absolutely term
and yet
and yet despite their politics are
sounding notes of real concern about
what they see within the world of comedy
and frankly the
strain toward anti-comedy is something
that should be supported yeah there is
one of the great ways the new right uses
comedy is that so much of the
evangelical left is about
sanctimoniousness piousness holier than
thou we're the anointed good people
thomas stahl has this great book called
division of the anointed and you guys
are not just wrong but you're bad and
evil people and we're here to save you
from yourselves it's domesticated
imperialism in many senses
so when you have social media being used
to mock denigrate and humiliate these
types as opposed to engage with them and
argue about the policies it's a very
effective technique and comedy i mean
this is not something that is original
to my thought has historically been you
know lenny bruce and going all the way
back uh you know to the court jester has
been the way to critique those in power
even the soviet union uh without having
to actually have you have that plausible
uh deniability you know reagan and
gorbachev would joke about this um and
it's it's a great and this is why social
media the social media giants are
freaking out because i think most people
don't appreciate how much existential
dread it causes people like jack dorsey
and his higher-ups to see that their uh
app and their their website is being
used in their mind subverted to further
ideas that they regard as unconscionable
and anathema key media figures
and whether you think they're part of
the new right or not tucker carlson
oh he's certainly
i see again i don't it would be a
function of whether they identify as
such but he's certainly one of their
hall of fame okay okay and and what do
you ascribe that someone who you know
came from a very waspy background came
from uh you know a perspective he you
know used to call himself a libertarian
in many ways now is sort of espousing
views that say
elizabeth warren is right about so many
different things and we need to pay
attention to that so is that kind of
emblematic of of how the new right
process works i think it's more
emblematic of the uh fact that he treats
the left with derision and contempt and
that he also regards them as not oh this
is a difference of opinion but these
people are out for your personal
destruction so having those kind that
kind of framing is a new right approach
uh
in terms of a lot of the other things
that we talked about here but we haven't
touched on yet you you mentioned the the
sort of corporate agenda aspect of this
but
is the new right gay friendly or not
because a lot of the different people
who we've mentioned and in terms of this
arc are people who
uh we're not just strongly opposed to
gay marriage but are strongly supportive
of the traditional family unit as being
the ideal well you're going to have a
complete range on the one hand you're
going to have the types who are like yes
we're the ones who are not socially
conservative at all
we're the ones who could bring
people who are gay lgbt uh into
right-wing thought because
if you are let's say post-progressive
and you want mass muslim migration
that's not going to be very
lgbt-friendly on the other hand you have
this the trad cons and this is you know
a certain other type of right wing who
think there is an agenda by the
corporate press to legitimize uh
pedophilia and and things like this and
to regard it as you know they're trying
to turn our kids into basically this
uh
non-sexual or uni um kind of a
demisexual type so you have the complete
range of everything in between what
about the trans community
well i think that there's again this is
something that's a very big split there
are those who are like whatever you want
to do that's fine and there are some who
think and this is with some uh reason
that the left will grab on to any
community it can at any given moment and
use that as a wedge issue to impose
their perspective on culture and here's
a great example of trans community
regardless of what you think of
transgender issues whether you're for
them or against them the fact that it
was put over that overnight if you were
not in favor of transgender bathrooms
you were ready to be read out of polite
society the fact that you had that
mechanism in place to put that whereas
transgender bathrooms are not the most
important issue for transgender people
it's being respect in your person it's
not being the victim of violence you
know it's being safe in your home being
able to talk to your family the fact
that this was the issue and that
everyone has to be talking about this
specific issue and that again this is
something we all decided upon it's one
mind that is the critique of
progressivism from the new right the
notice how quickly that went in the
garbage when that wasn't put over and
now it's something else and now it's
these so-called concentration camps and
right away we all have amnesia
one of the things that comes with the
trans agenda is the argument over
pronouns
and we've seen that hit not not just
people who are on the right in fact
there's examples most recently a
professor at uh at uh uc uh
santa barbara who
was
herself a liberal feminist described
herself as being someone on the left um
just you know had an intersectional
perspective on a lot of different things
but was also emphatic that a man can't
become a woman sure and has heard from
all sorts of corners of
uh disgust with that uh scenario
that aspect of this of this agenda do
you think that that's prodding a lot of
people to
have a more aggressive and perhaps more
new right sympathetic feeling i think
that's more of a conservative
perspective and i also would add to this
notice the head of planned parenthood
she was just fired because she was
referring to women having reproductive
choices opposed to people with wounds or
whatever they wanted to phrase it um i i
think again this is a socially
conservative thing it's much more that
than a new right
perspective because again when
when this was the issue you know like
this fashions are closed right paul
graham had this great essay called what
you can say and he talks about you know
every year you're going to have
fashionable issues so this is a
left-wing issue du jour so the fact that
you are engaging with it as opposed to
picking your own issue du jour is much
more of a conservative perspective but
there's a broader point here which i
discuss in the book which is how the
left uses jargon as a mechanism to have
dominance and social control and every
so often the slang changes you can't say
legal alien and right away if you use
the correct expression that's a signal
to the in group that you're one of them
as opposed to one of the bad guys
and that that terminology that use of
language
how have you seen that ramped up in the
social media age oh i mean it's
extraordinary i mean it's very obvious
uh you know who's much faster it's move
right and and the thing is you know
there's all of these mechanisms that
because you'll have let's say your
twitter or your facebook or something
they'll say okay you can't use certain
words right and then it becomes like
project runway or top chef where you
have these talented people forced to
operate under constraints and the
consequences are often creative but in
this case you don't want people to be
creative so if you say okay if you use
like the slur the n word on this site
you're going to be banned well then they
just start referring to people of color
as n words now is that really better
because it sounds more creative and it
sounds more engaging and now those young
people get to so-called stick it to the
man and be defiant so it ends up
shooting them in the foot in my view the
uh concept of horseshoe theory explain
that for us horseshoe theory which i do
not ascribe to and subscribe to and i
think is is kind of silly is the idea
that the far left and the far right are
essentially the same and it's like a big
horseshoe and eventually when they meet
they're indistinguishable and in this
context it would be something like gavin
mcinnes's the proud boys being the same
thing as antifa and any kind of
equivocation in my mind often tends to
be a function of uh either laziness or
someone who hasn't done their homework
that uh theory though is something that
i've seen deployed quite a lot and
particularly i think it's being deployed
in the context of the political where
you can see you know some uh people you
know because of the anti-war views for
example sure you know supporting someone
not just like gabbard but other people
who might be more critical yes while
having very leftist domestic policy
views
does horseshoe theory
where do you see the points where it
just kind of breaks down where it falls
apart and it has sort of an overly
simplistic view yeah one of these is
like this kind of uh
boomer argument that uh stalin and
hitler were basically the same well as a
jewish person it's very interesting
who's alive it is very interesting to me
to be told that life for me would have
been the same under nazi germany as it
was for my family under stalin they're
both terrible but they're terrible in
different ways so that's one example
another example is this claim that you
know both sides are centurious which is
true but everyone has their own things
that they regard as heresy and taboo
this is a universal function of human
culture and society so in terms of how
would apply in terms of practice and
what you would glean from it i find it
to be very little value
one thing that seems to me to be
consistent though about this horseshoe
theory argument is that
within the corporate media landscape
people on the sort of the new right
general's vicinity and people on the uh
sort of anti-corporate left vicinity are
both people who both factions of people
who have traditionally been shut out of
the conversation that's taking place
when you look at the editorial pages of
the major media you know landscape
you know it's notable not just how few
voices there are who are in favor of the
president but also how few voices there
were prior to 2016 and continue to this
day who are critical of the standard
clintonian approach of democratic
politics
is that one example where horseshoe
theory is does hold a little bit and if
so why oh i agree yeah so there is very
much this kind of since they're both
outsiders since they're both heretics in
a sense
and unorthodox there is an enormous
amount of skepticism on both sides of
the extreme right and extreme left you
want to use the term extreme towards the
establishment and towards the
the the idea that these are good people
or better than us
and you see it with you know all the
attacks by the so-called squad against
nancy pelosi implying that she's a
racist these are attacks that they would
use against biden as well and that they
use against president trump so there is
very much a skepticism but for any
outsider it's not even just politics of
how things are currently run and the
belief that okay maybe we should tear
this down and build something better or
not build something better the uh the
thrust the of this agenda from both uh
the far left and the far right
and you know not saying anything about
how many people inhabit those those
veins
is certainly part of the conversation
that we see playing out over and over
again in the corporate media but in
other places as well about increased
polarization in american life uh there
is no escape from the political that you
no longer even can go to a ballpark or a
game without having to take a position
on something and worrying about who's
cheering next to you uh that's something
to me that
is historically pretty un-american it's
happened before in american history you
know we shouldn't ignore that civil war
civil war absolutely being an example of
that but really in the in the sort of
post-war modern american environment it
seems you know like that's something
that stands out as being different from
the experience of a lot of people do you
think that's something that is a
permanent trajectory for american life
or is it something that's temporary oh i
think it's going to escalate uh thanks
to social media as you're encouraged to
have your views driven to their logical
conclusion the new right perspective on
it is this that with the rise of fdr and
basically the complete discrediting of
the right wing and you know we
outflanded who ran against him in 96 in
excuse me 36 you know it was basically a
me too guy and for decades uh the
republicans were the metoo party and
they had to be because there was no uh
right of center i should just interject
you mean me too not in the hashtag not
in the hashtag but that was the old
expression the me to republicans barry
goldwater was basically the first robert
taft to some lesser extent figure to
basically say okay we're going to stand
for something different he referred to
eisenhower as a dive store new deal and
he his election in 64 was a huge debacle
huge loss and lyndon johnson's landslide
was unprecedented so basically when i
guess with the loss of the fairness
doctrine and when you did not have to
have two corporately approved
perspectives in the rise of reagan and
you had this increased radicalization
and unused negative sense on the right
that is when it was like all right now
we're going to have two different
ideologies and we're going to encourage
people to
increasingly self-segregate and we saw
this in the presidential debates when
you had uh which would have been
unthinkable
in 88 uh even in 2008 when you had the
candidates yelling at the moderators and
being like these ted cruz you know
screaming these questions are what kind
of questions are these this is not what
people care about this would never have
happened 20 years ago because the
perception was the press is objective
and honest and good and now it's the
okay they have an agenda not just a bias
and agenda and they are people we have
to grapple with
if you look at the polling data a
majority of the people who actually
supported president trump in 2016 also
have views on immigration that are far
more moderate than you might expect
in fact you know they're open to not
just steps on the dreamers but a lot of
other steps that i think would really
surprise some people given the voices
that speak on immigration
tell me a little bit about how that
interacts with the new right is this a
situation where people are painted into
sort of a corner on immigration as a hot
button issue where they feel like they
need to take a hard line
is there a run or gamut of different
opinions on the new writer ann coulter's
probably the one who took point on this
because her perspective is this uh it
makes as much sense for republicans to
be trying to get minority voice votes as
it would be for democrats to try to get
evangelical christian votes you go to
where the votes are and her point of
view is if you have this uh open or
quasi-open immigration and you have
people coming here with no historical
background in america they are going to
it and data
points this out they are going to tend
to vote democrat and and left-wing
democrat you see california is the
example that they use so for them it
becomes a function of why are we giving
votes to people who aren't going to vote
like we like and they they're i mean
they're to the right of the republican
party it's so to them it's like this is
just a suicide pact and in fact the the
left will have you say this kind of idea
that demographic change in america is
both a conspiracy theory of the
alt-right and an inevitability that's
going to lead to destruction the
republican party in perpetuity
uh coulter is someone who obviously
supported the president very strongly
and now has become a critic of him
because she believes he's failed to live
up to his obligations on immigration is
that a new right phenomenon as well
shared not just by her but by others oh
yeah i mean there again there's always
been skepticism from him the idea that
uh you know in trump we trust is it was
in the right slogan is false they tongue
and she call him a god emperor because
they you know like that he so called
owens the libs but there was never in my
view uh across the soul spectrum this
belief that he's the one who's going to
uh save this country uh and then that
they also understand again because
politics is downstream culture this is
going to be a far longer battle and it's
not going to be a battle that's being
held in washington it's being held in
the universities and the streets is this
a situation where they value more a
president who will weigh in and defend
say the covington kids or something like
that than one who's pushing forward some
piece of legislation or policy well it
would depend on the policy in the
legislation but the covington kids was a
great example because it there's an
asymmetry if i sit down and tell we're
friends and i tell you 90 truths and 10
lies you're going to look at me as a
liar even though 90 of the time i'm
telling the truth so when you have
things like the covington case and you
have the shamelessness of the press
urging you know basically violence
toward these kids who just stood there
with the smirk on their face which is
basically you know uh nuremberg and a
hate crime and then when you know the
full footage came out and it's this
adult getting his face there was very
little
oh oops we're going to do better next
time in fact lawsuits happened as a
consequence of this and we saw it again
with kavanaugh and other instances like
this and uh eachine carol recently on
cnn talking about her brave fantasies
are sexy and uh anderson cooper can get
to commercial fast enough so when you
have what are called these red pill
moments that realization of oh these
aren't mistakes because you can make a
mistake once twice but if it's a pattern
at a certain point that's a behavior not
a mistake so that is i think the the
perspective that uh rather than what
president trump has to say is that these
are the moments that let people realize
just how depraved the corporate press is
that uh war with the press that you talk
about is one that shows up when you look
at the statistics
the levels of decline in faith in the
american media particularly among
republican voters but also among
independents as well has been steep and
it's been you know something that uh
that the media really doesn't seem to be
able to help its way out of right let's
say that you are in charge of one of
these media companies or that you have a
significant role within it what could
you do differently
uh i think i would have much more varied
perspectives um i think i would have a
kind of a council around me where people
would have different points of view
jonathan high talks about this having uh
intellectual header and like heterodox
kind of points of view it would be tough
because whenever you're running a
corporation in a progressive uh culture
you're going to have your hands tied by
higher ups and by
the backlash so they're in a tough
position i'm not going to deny that but
at the same time it doesn't need to be
as brazen and heavy-handed and shameless
as it tends to be
if uh people obviously uh they can get
together
for the new right perspective the battle
is won when the typical corporate
journalist is regarded exactly as a
tobacco executive
the perspective that people can get on
the new right from your book is
obviously one
that is significant it's gotten a lot of
praise from some very smart people
but if they were going to look and read
other people as well what what books
should they turn to what additional
tomes would you recommend
in terms of contemporary books i don't
think there's any
and that's why i wrote it i wouldn't
write a book that was redundant i mean
there are many books around this space
that basically want to function everyone
as a function of the clan whereas at the
very least the members of this group who
identify as clans people is virtually
nil the new york times recently had a
piece a1 you know above the fold about a
kid from west virginia who started
watching ben shapiro videos and then
watched white nationalist videos and
he's like i'm not a white nationalist
anymore and this is an anecdote of one
data point this is supposed to be
indicative of something so i i but in
terms of books that provide background
to this i would say definitely the works
of pat buchanan the works of murray
rothbard the works of ayn rand james
burnham's the machiavellian is the
quintessential text here um and coulter
who i quote at length in the book would
be the kind of big ones michael malus's
book is the new right a journey to the
fringe of american politics thank you so
much for taking time to join us today
thank you ben
this and all of our afterwards programs
are available as podcasts and can be
viewed on our website